so my name is David Nolan I'm gonna talk
a bit about closure script in court
async how many people here have ever
read about cores communicating
sequential processes cool that's good
has anybody ever programmed have tried
using go lang
Rob Pike's : only one okay has anybody
use the language that actually
implements CSP I mean go as one so not
that many so this is something that I
think is really really funny that it's
something that nearly everybody's heard
of but nobody's tried there's been
language in the past you had um akhom
pie for the trans pewter you had
concurrent ml which was a variant of
standard ml that supported CSP um and go
is actually really making waves right
people really like it I don't really
like it but I think the CSP aspect of it
is actually pretty cool it's very and
very much holds very closely to Tony
Hoare his ideas so rich Iggy decided
more or less to just copy like goes and
sort of interpretation of Tony hores
original ideas so I'm not going to
assume that you know too much about CSP
and so we'll go slow but we'll end up
going fast later so it won't be boring
if you think you know this stuff has
anybody here tried croasing okay cool
cool
sweet so that's good we'll get to cool
if you tried it then you'll see some
cool stuff if I'm moving too fast just
raise your hand and ask a question
because I've looked at this stuff so
long I'm probably going to just assume
that you can read my mind
and that's probably simply not true so
stop me if something doesn't make sense
so I'm not going to talk about Korey
sink in the context of closure for the
JVM this is all oriented around
clojurescript I do front-end development
JavaScript at the New York Times I've
been doing javascript for eight years
now doing user interfaces I've done user
interfaces in Java Objective C I've
written C++ C
I've done them in um God just about
everything right and it's all sort of
variations on things that I don't
particularly like so I got kind of
excited about CSP because I think it's a
better fit for the types of things that
you end up doing in a sort of user
interface
this was actually explored in concurrent
ml or was a thing called Exene and also
Rob Pike had done some pretty cool X
Windows stuff in the 80s with one of his
various CSP like languages I mean Rob
Pike has basically been writing the same
language for 20 years now and he finally
hit the jackpot with go but he was also
excited about the possibility of doing
you eyes with CSP okay so here we have a
JavaScript file I'm using line clgs bill
which is a very popular sort of build
tool I'm just gonna have it on auto
compile so I'm gonna just save stuff
like save my file it's gonna recompile
we're gonna refresh in the browser so we
have a namespace form up here
I've excluded some of these operations
that are are part of the standard
library because I want to be able to
Matt filter remove and call distinct as
channel operations not as operations
over sequences right so this is a map
filter reduce functional programming oh
you know I'm assuming you guys know
about that
so I'm gonna import the async stuff so
I'll explain this when we get there but
I'm bringing some interesting stuff and
I need to bring in the macros that allow
this sort of magic to happen so
essentially what chorusing provides it
provides this thing called a go block
inside of a go block you can actually do
what look appears to be async ops
synchronously so you have the illusion
of doing things synchronously and this
eliminates the sort of callback hell so
if you've done anything with evented
programming whether it's Python or
JavaScript or Java you have you know
inner classes I mean it just sucks right
if you've done a lot of that type of
thing it's not fun so go this inversion
of control problem inside of a go block
it it gives you the illusion that you
can do these things in a synchronous
manner so that you don't have to like
write your code in continuation
passing style manually so here I have a
go block and I just want to sort of sort
the semantics if you have a go block it
always returns a channel so so the
result of a go block is always a channel
so if I I have a demo page here I'm
going to refresh this and you can see
that I console.log the result from a go
block and I get back a channel so the
result of a go block is always a channel
not 5 right so it seems a bit strange I
returned 5 but actually what's gonna
happen is that 5 is inside that channel
right the channel has that value but I
haven't read it out now
I want to be able to read something out
of that channel and so if I'm not
familiar with core async I might think
that I can do this I'm going to
console.log go 5 and it should return 5
in a channel I'm going to try to read
from the channel the angle bracket bang
is like read a value off a channel if
you have a channel and I'm going to get
a nice little error here says you can't
do that you can't do a read right
outside of go blocks if you want to have
this illusion of being able to do things
asynchronously without writing callbacks
you have to do all your operations
inside the go block this may sound
limiting but you'll see that you can
actually do quite a bit in closure just
to explain in closure you can do this
with the angle bracket double bang right
so you're allowed to do reads off of
channels outside of a go block but it
means that you could potentially tie up
a thread right so you can do angle
double bang or left what greater than
double bang which is a plinth right you
can read you can read or put or take
from a channel okay so now that I have
now that I know this I can mean well
that's okay I'm just gonna wrap that
expression in another go block and then
I can use I can do a read off that
channel
and then we see console.log five which
is what we want right so we're allowed
to do puts and takes on channels with
the put and take operator as long as
we're inside of a go block okay so the
primitives are really go blocks and
channels and we want we have put and
take operations so here I have a make a
channel and then I have a go block and I
say we got here and I print that I read
off the channel and then I write this
another console.log statement it says
we'll never get here and this seems a
bit strange I'll explain so the
semantics of CSP is that writes and
reads when you put and you take there
has to be some but if I put something
somebody has to take from the other side
otherwise inside that go block it just
becomes a suspended operation if I take
and there's nothing there on the channel
then again the operation is going to
suspend until somebody puts something so
this is really important and it's very
much how go-go Lang works and how the
original CSP model is defined
synchronous operations right so in order
for this to work all the magic and Cori
sink is about sort of enclosure script
making it appear that we have
lightweight threads so that's that so
that we're not actually going to be
eating up threads when we're waiting for
something to happen
does anybody confused about I just said
okay read that take a value off the
channel take a value out the channel
so so the channel the channel is it's
not a place it's a conduit right I can
put stuff on to it sort of into it so
that people can take things out or I can
take things out right the only thing
that's important is that if I take try
to take something out there's nothing
there
my mice I'm gonna be suspended until
somebody put something there you go oh
okay good good question you can put
anything you want though I recommend
putting immutable values and so you
don't get it's dated purely dynamic so
it's not like it's not like an in go so
in go Google's go you had you have to
you have to give the channel a tight so
that these are untyped channels we can
put anything we want though you really
should put immutable values so you can
avoid the problem you haven't go with
race conditions you can have data races
if you put mutable values onto a channel
right so we don't have that problem
anything you put in will come out the
other end that's one of the most the
coolest things you can do you can put a
channel channel is their first class so
you can put channels on the channels and
there's really cool tricks you can do
with that good questions keep asking
good questions cuz like I know you can't
read my mind
alright so this is kind of interesting
I can run so whenever I have a go block
remember it's sort of like it's sort of
like a even though this is JavaScript
it's as if we had this magical ability
to start threads like right start these
lightweight threads at the same time so
here I have a make a channel and I'm
gonna write a JavaScript date on to the
channel which is actually not a great
idea cuz I put a mutable value on the
channel so I didn't do what I said not
to do and then in the other go block I'm
gonna read it right and so this is kind
of interesting because what I what I
show here sorry I skipped ahead let's go
up here
okay so I'd make a channel it's gonna
we're gonna get go there and we're gonna
be able to make progress because I have
a separate go block that writes
something into the channel so that the
top guy can proceed this sounds pretty
crazy right because these the the code
is out of order but we're still going to
get progress right so that's kind of
interesting so what this means is that
first go block is gonna run it's going
to get suspended by the read the next go
blocks and a run allowing the code above
to continue make sense and then you know
all I've done here is it's the exact
same it's the exact same code I just
flip things around so this is but this
is very interesting so on the top on the
top one we're gonna write into the
channel even though I have no
expressions later there it's going to be
suspended right because until the bottom
go block reads and I can show that you
that this is true by going
after
right because because nobody read it but
if I do this boom
totally works it's pretty cool so ah
right so this is this is the essence so
you already can see that there's all
these amazing games you can play right
because you actually have really fine
grain control now over asynchronous
operations which is not normally true
when you're doing async stuff okay
so let's see less trivial stuff things
that are more real-world so here is a
very simple thing called events and what
it does is it creates it takes a Dom
event and it converts it into a channel
which will output those events as they
happen so here I can I can say you know
this is going to be an HTML element it's
going to be the type of event I want to
listen to in the Dom and what we're
gonna do is we're going to add a
listener on that element of that
particular type and we're going to put
each event onto that Channel and you
notice events returns a channel so this
is a very common pattern you construct
you can do you construct some source and
you get a channel as a value so you can
listen on it or you can write to it or
whatever does that make sense so there's
all like you're gonna see a lot of like
constructing channel functions yes
so this is this is read and if it's the
other if they if it's the other
direction it's put this sorry take I
should say I should fix my terminology
this is take oh okay so why do I have
this so this is this is you can call put
and take which are the basically the
async versions of these guys like this
is actually a a synchronous put so that
I don't have to be inside of a go block
to put something to any channel right I
told you that these guys can only be
used inside a go blocks but there are
places where like we're not we're not in
the asynchronous world yet we're not
inside of a sort of a channel thing yet
so we need some way to get things into
the channel outside of the rest of the
world right so put and take are the N
are the async analogs of these which
have the semantics of being synchronous
when you're in a go block okay so so
this is kind of crazy so this is one of
these cool things that like if you're
into functional programming you're like
wow this is pretty nuts
I can here this look this this looks
like you would not terminate right I say
go while true which means this will run
forever and we're gonna what did what
its gonna do is what's gonna happen this
works because if I don't move the mouse
this go block doesn't do anything if I
move the mouse it's going to read it
print it loop around and if I stop
moving the mouse it's not gonna do
anything so this is like a this is like
a mini event loop so unlike this this
thing where we normally have like one
giant event loop we can actually make
mini event loops with grasing so I'm
gonna reload this let me get all our
mouse events right so and that that's
pretty nice we can sort of Express
through and you're gonna see it we can
actually use this recursion as a pretty
cool way to maintain state like we can
actually hold state in the loop and
that's if you if you read up on
concurrent ml you see that they do this
trick this is not a new idea at all
okay so I want to be able to map over
channels like I'm gonna I have a channel
and what I want to do is I want to take
a channel and for every event that I get
out of that channel I want to apply some
function and write it to another channel
right so this is sort of like the first
channel transformation that we've that
we were going to see so it takes it
takes some function which wouldn't apply
to every value that comes out of in and
what do we do we make a channel called
out and forever we're going to read from
in apply F write it to out okay so
here's my little function I want to map
over every event I want to instead I
don't want to deal with this crazy Dom
event I want like a nice little vector
that represents the mouse coordinates so
this will take a raw Dom mouse event and
it's going to extract out the page X and
page why I'm going to return a vector so
it look this looks pretty cool I can
take the mouse move I can map eat a V
and that gives me a new channel and
forever I want to read from move print
its value out to the JavaScript console
there we go
cool that's pretty nice we can do filter
right so this I mean this is this is
really just the phone this is the
channel versions of functional
operations you guys are probably seen
before
so here we take some predicate function
we take the end channel and forever
we're gonna read from in if it passes
the predicate we're gonna write it to
out so down here what I do I'm gonna
make this ridiculous predicate which
says only if X is divisible by five and
Y is divisible by 10 are we going to do
anything but this is kind of nice
everything composes so I have the
original source I convert into a vector
of numbers and then I filter out the
ones that that are where the X component
is divisible by five and the y component
is divisible by 10 and then I you know I
print out the contents so you're gonna
see here that that's the only thing the
only values that appear
well but we accept what you're asking
for is impossible right I mean there's
no way there's no way like it's just a
different kind of operation there's no
way to unify this the real synchronous
world in a synchronous world
they can't be unified it's not possible
does that answer crimey n-- there's no
way to do it right a sync stuff is a
sync stuff okay so this is where it gets
really fun so there's go ahead so
futures are much more monadic right so
every time you do something to your
future you're going to get a new future
you do you do you do in any new channel
but you but for every event you don't
get it you don't have to construct
anything new this is something that I
don't like about promise or future based
models is that every step you have to
review you have to construct something
whereas I can generate a pipeline and
it's constructed once
so all those Mouse events that are
flowing through the system I only
constructed in this case three channels
whereas in a future based model every
event at every step in the pipeline
needs a future
so Elam uses well I don't want to get
too far down but ll is very cool it's an
implementation in five FRP and it tries
to solve these FRPs problems I mean what
I'm demonstrating is very FRP like FRP
does do one thing which i did not
realize that it did it it makes a very
big design trade-off because it wants
you to be able to use signals in a very
functional way but in order to do this
it actually imposes a global ordering on
all events so there's a cost associated
with this and then the CSP model we say
that's really not we don't want to pay
that price so CSP gives you the
primitives to manage synchronization but
it does mean occasionally you have to go
in there and make sure that things
happen in the right order
whereas Elm tries to do that for you but
at this sort of like global cost that
every every part of your programs gonna
pay for
so I mean people way smarter than me
know about this okay so if reading I'm
not gonna explain this but Eric Meyer
worked for years on this on C sharps
async/await
we use the exact same compilation
strategy as C sharps async/await and
async/await is basically what theorists
say is como netic so quarry sink is also
similarly como netic i have no idea what
that means but I can show you what you
can do with it okay so what this is
pretty cool so in so javascript is
single threaded
but quarry sink actually allows us to do
things that I know everybody wants to do
like there's so many times you're like I
wish I could sleep right I wish I could
sleep and not block everything right so
Cory sink lets us do this with time out
channels so time I channels are a great
idea that we're copied from go the go
language and basically it's a channel
that will block execution and after a
certain milliseconds it will it will the
channel will close which also Lau allows
progress so here I'm going to write it
as even though it appears that I've
written these statements one after the
other I can sleep for a second twice so
let's
so that's that's another good question
so we just use so on the JVM it's super
complicated in that they use an executor
pool and there's all these locks around
channels all this stuff in JavaScript
you don't have to do that because
JavaScript is single threaded um so what
we do for the dispatch mechanism is we
pick whatever's fastest JavaScript
actually is a variety of things you can
use the slowest is set timeout set
timeout has a latency of about five to
six milliseconds which is actually
unacceptable for a lot of patterns so we
use that as the worst fallback otherwise
we use something called a message
channel there's so there's a way to
communicate between Windows and browsers
now that as much lower latency and we
also use set immediate which is present
in an explorer as well as nodejs um and
set a media is really fast so you can do
I'm not going to demonstrate it but
there's a really nice benchmark and go
where it's good where you do thread ring
right you make 1000 1000 channels and
you push a value through it on one side
and how long does it take to get out the
other side go can do this in like 60 to
80 milliseconds core async and chrome
can do in about 160 which is only twice
as slow which is pretty wild right and
that's through the dispatch mechanism
that we that we have just in the browser
so it's pretty good okay so that's
pretty neat time out channels okay
whoops sorry
so non-deterministic choice so often
when you write a piece of a synchronous
code you want your little block of code
to do something based on whether this
happens or that happens whether the
check you look you're basically you want
to listen in on multiple channels and
whoever gives you a value first you want
to sort of conditionally operate on that
does that sort of makes sense so so it's
a waiter like take multiple inputs and
process them as they arrive
right so this in go this is called
select right quick questions about that
so here I'm gonna make a channel and I'm
gonna make a time out channel and this
primitive this primitive operations
called alts and you give it a vector of
channels so this is a sort of
first-class operation you can actually
you can actually grow and shrink that
vector and you can do really cool tricks
because this is not um an NGO it's
static unless you use reflection by
default and closure it's dynamic so you
select dynamically over vector so of
course C is never going to provide a
value because we never put anything into
it but the time out channel will provide
a value and so you saw after a second
you know the time out channel closed
right but oh and I should explain this
so what alts returns alts returns the
value that was read off the channel as
part of a vector and I'm destructuring
it here so this is the value and this is
the channel that responded right that
actually responded so you can see this
way you can do conditional matching like
did this channel respond or did that
channel respond this allows you to do
conditional logic when a channel closes
you get known yes and the Nu and that
actually it's important you can't put
nil on a channel but nil is 8 is a sort
of terminal value right so it actually
if you try to put nil on a channel it's
going to throw and if you read it nil
off a channel you know it's closed
okay so there is alternate syntax which
you can use which makes
alt the ulting operation look a little
bit more like cond
which is the closures version of if else
so here is the same code but here I can
go alt and I can say you know either the
channel which I never it's never gonna
respond because there's no value on it
or the time out channel and what you do
is it'll Pat like I'm matching on this
channel or I'm matching on that channel
and then I get the value here as a
parameter to that the body this is like
basically an implicit body of a lambda
if you run this guy same thing it's no
different just it's just sugar so it's
like sugar for matching on a particular
channel so I could have written this
like this right I'm gonna do a little
bit of live coding con P equal like that
I can go if it equaled C log J's console
the channel and a value or closed
and hopefully it flips okay to make any
mistakes oh I love I love closure script
it gives me an errors all right so we
should see the same thing happen yes so
it's just sugar for doing that right
it's just sugar for conditionally
matching on which channel respondent
makes sense okay so here's where it gets
really fun so we can hold we can hold
when we do the recursion we can use I've
been using while while true just to
represent sort of an infinite recursion
but here we can we can we can make a
loop and we can store State in the loop
so this is this is a channel which in
which enforces that we only get distinct
values out of it we're only going to get
distinct value of this channel so if
somebody puts in the same value more
than once we're only going to see the
first time that it appeared which is
very useful in user interfaces
so here's distinct it takes a channel
and here's the out channel we're gonna
loop the last value that we saw of
course initializes to nil we're gonna
read it in as long as what we read in is
not equal to last then we can write it
to the out and then we recur right so
this this this will only write to out
when we get a unique value so here once
it once again it's like all this stuff
composes in like a functional way except
it's asynchronous programming so I've
got key presses I'm gonna convert them
into their key codes I only care about
the key codes i'll they want the
distinct key codes i'm gonna print them
out so if I'm up here and I'm pressing D
it only worked once I'm pressing a F
if I start typing lots of different keys
okay but right I can't repeat a key
I'm sorry because I was just typing
really fast like what Keith yes oh yes
it's only yari it's it's gotta be in a
secret but of course you could I could I
could keep memory like I could so its
debt that's is actually fun okay so here
we're we're gonna we're gonna exactly
never again oops we're gonna call this
scene
when not contain seen and we're gonna do
is we're in a we're going to cange
seeing the next live coding code review
does it look right so I haven't starting
set if I've seen it if I haven't seen it
before we write it out I add it to the
scene set and hopefully this is gonna
work and then I got a never again
okay
there we go
oh I'm running out of keys alright
that's pretty cool so we can hold state
in the loop okay so here is a possible
implementation for something called fan
in which some like P some people might
call merge so Fannin can take a vector
of channels as many as you want and it's
gonna it's gonna merge them into a
single channel right so this is really
useful you have tons of inputs coming in
and you want to be able to read from one
thing you don't want to have to manage
all these different sources you can
merge them into a single source so how
does this work we have a vector of ends
but this is what's really cool about
this is alts takes a vector so this is
trivial to write right all already takes
a vector of channels so whenever I get
some I'll and I only care about the
value I don't care about which one
responded and I can just write out write
that out write that value out so this
will take a bunch of different things
and write out um I'm gonna Smoove a bit
more quickly because I don't want to
talk forever so I want to demonstrate
here that one thing that's really cool
about CSP is CSP works as both a push
and pull system right so this is really
important I can make generators right
remember I said if if I write and nobody
reads right then I have a process that's
stuck but I can make something I can
make a process that simply is a
generator so that I can source values
out of it right it's not actually
generating its values asynchronously
it's just it's just something I want to
be able to stream things out of so this
is what this is this is an int this is a
channel that just simply produces intz
and we can do this because we can hold
the current integer inside the loop
right so if somebody starts reading off
of this they're gonna start getting
integers starting at one here's a
different channel which is also pretty
useful it's a channel where you've given
a millisecond delay it will simply bang
a value onto the channel it's just going
to put the current date at different
intervals so you could use this to
throttle something right you could you
can think about it you can start using
these different channels and
compose them so you could use this to
throttle another channel right so here
this one's kind of big and I kind of
don't do I okay I'll explain this as
quickly as I possibly can
so what I want to show here is that we
can sort of do cooperative multi sort of
sort of multi-threading even though that
JavaScript doesn't have native threads
so I can construct a process and give it
a name and then I can give it a control
channel and this is actually a very
common pattern so the control channel if
I ever write to it it's gonna turn that
process on or off so think about this I
can construct end channels and I can use
their controls to say it's your turn to
start computing stop it's your turn to
start computing stop and so on and this
is this is quite cool I want to show
other things so I'm not going to dive
into exactly how this works but let's
just see that it does in fact do what I
say that it does so you're gonna see
what's gonna happen is every time I
press spacebar so the process I'm using
the interval and I'm using int so it's
is a generator and I'm using the bang
from the interval channel to generate
the integers if I press spacebar it's
gonna switch and I have multiple loops
going on here so I'm not just doing the
integers channel I'm actually using it
as an accumulator so I have an inner
loop which is actually reading off of
each process and then adding you know
the the next set of integers if I press
spacebar again I go back precisely to
where I was in the other process right
so this is pretty complicated right I've
composed a bunch of channels and I
basically can do sort of like
cooperative multitasking
so you you have to handle that case
because if you because what'll happen if
you don't handle it you'll probably
accidentally right right right Anil into
another channel and that'll blow up
you'll get an error you know let me I'll
tell you what you do you'll only get in
a runtime so you you if you know so when
you design your system yeah you just
have to handle you check the handle
closing so I I kept my case simple
because you you want to be more robust
but there were there was no such thing
as fan-in so I wrote it there is now
something called merge which handles
closing so I would just use the provided
merge so a lot of the stuff that I'm
showing you don't use my versions there
are now official versions of these
operators that that are robust enough
for that
so so a lot of those libraries just they
require tu use functional composition
and so a lot of what I'm showing you is
I get I get I get to write regular
closure code like I don't have to write
everything in terms of combinators so if
you're gonna do a sync je s you're sort
of limited so everything has to be
combined via functions which may or may
not be nice depending on what you're
doing I won't go that I would hate to
write in that style I've seen people
doing that style that's horrible
but that's the main difference is that a
lot this this go inside of a go block
because it transforms your code for you
into a stick machine you get to write
your code in a natural style you don't
have to do everything through functional
composition so here's it here's here's a
pretty cool non-trivial thing this is
actually a port of some go code so this
is something that I know people write in
Java or haven't had to write in
JavaScript me we do JavaScript so this
I'm gonna run what I want to do I'm
going to show this code so what I want
to do here is I want to run three
queries at the same time each query runs
two possible queries that might return
right I want to run a web one query web
2 query where image 1 image - video 1
video 2 I want to print out three
results right so whoever which whether
web one returns first or what two
returns first I want the fastest one of
those two and I want the entire thing to
have an 80 millisecond timeout right
imagine writing that in JavaScript
that's not gonna be fun but this this is
basically we get to write the code
pretty much how we would describe it I
write two fastest queries I write them
into the channel I have a timeout of 80
milliseconds on the whole thing and
that's it so if I run this
so web one image one video one image two
web one video one nobody returned a
result within 80 milliseconds this is a
type of thing that you often want to be
able to write very succinctly but you
often writing kind of a big mess and so
Cory sink really lets us sort of avoid
those messes when we're doing a lot of
asynchronous code that makes it okay so
we're going to get quite a bit fancier
so here's just a bunch of boilerplate
around the note the Dom yes
so though they're do they keep going so
again if you want to make him more
robust you'll have to prove each one of
those processes should take leak they
cancel right so that's something I again
I I'm trying to keep my example simple
so that you just get you can mostly get
it this is entire repos on github
so you can you can run these examples
yourself well what yeah yeah the address
yes okay so I mean they are they are
queues the channels are queues
fundamentally but we get a nicer
interface towards them I mean you
normally have okay so I want to sort of
talk a bit about what I actually
described in my in the description of
this talk which is how we can sort of
take these primitives and build
extremely responsive interfaces so I'm
going to show you that I can use the
exact same code for doing lists item
selection like like highlighting I can
use the same code whether I'm targeting
the Dom or whether I'm like making a
text adventure game I can actually use
the exact same async handling code for
both interfaces it doesn't matter so
what does it look like
here is the selection the selector the
selection process so what it does is it
takes an end channel and the end channel
is basically has a bunch of events and
I've decided we're gonna see what these
events are and then we take something
that represents the list this could be
something in the Dom or it could be a
JavaScript array which we're going to
use to render to like some text
adventure game and then the list of
things that are to be selected we're
gonna produce an out Channel so when we
start when we enter that when we
construct the selector obviously nothing
is selected if we get an event on in
right then we you need to handle it so
if the channel closed we say boom
selection process is done if we got a
select event then what do we do we write
out the selected piece of data to out
and then we recur setting the loop the
state in the loop to be whatever was
currently selected otherwise we received
a number
which is telling us you know which thing
should be skirt we should be selected
well what I mean actually and I'm
confusing this highlighted which thing
to highlight basically and if we had a
number we unselect the previous selected
thing if if we get out oh sorry if we
get out so if you mouse out like this so
if I mouse out and there's nothing
should be selected we clear the
selection if I get a number then we want
to select that thing we select it and we
recur so again I wish I had more time
but you could look at this code later
but the idea is I haven't a channel
which has either select something or a
number to highlight something so let's
demo this
so what we're gonna do is we have up
we're gonna we're going to grab the Dom
element we're gonna allow hovering over
the and that is list element ul and
we're gonna allow hovering we're gonna
have a hovered channel over the UL for
each of the Li elements we're gonna
allow Keith we're gonna allow movement
by key if I press up or down so this is
this is gonna be we're gonna fan in
right we're gonna allow hovering over it
select highlighting something in the
list whether it's a mouse or whether
it's keys we're gonna support selecting
if we click right and then we're gonna
make a selector and see we can fan in we
can fan in three independent streams of
events hover events click events and
clicks this is why phantom egg merging
streams is is really nice the other
thing is that like if you've done a lot
of JavaScript you often like spread your
event handling code all over the place
and this is like you can actually
collect all your event handling into one
logical location so let's run this guy
what'd I do wrong
thanks again
sorry
okay
so there we have our hover
I can use my use the arrows I can I can
click and you see it prints out the
result down there and what I want to
show is that we can apply the exact same
thing to a text adventure representation
so here you're going to note this is
literally almost identical right so I
just want to I just want to use the the
window as the source of the key events
and they're just a bunch of details
around that but you notice the selector
this the critical function is unchanged
it's gonna be there's not going to be
any difference for for doing this
different visual representation so there
it is down there at the bottom right so
this is pretty this is this is to me
like one of the biggest ideas and
something that I've been looking for for
a very long time when it comes to the UI
programming which is that we design our
UIs around about around events but at a
really abstract level a wait you know
separated from I'm not gonna build
something in the Dom am I gonna build
something on the iPhone and it's gonna
use touches or is using the mouse clicks
or I'm gonna mate I'm gonna have to do a
text UI or I have to do it an
audio-based UI or Braille right what
people actually end up rewriting these
components over and over and over again
for every possible target but with with
this model where we actually really
abstract out away from the concrete
event sources then we can have really
truly reusable components we don't have
to rewrite that logic so I have
what's the Wi-Fi here
a password oh there's no public one
that's okay
I work yeah
Oh
oh docker
David's a fun
No oh yeah I see it there we go
sweet
okay
let's try again no no it's gonna work
alright so if you want to know more
about this I've written like tons of
blog posts so starting with like this
one there's a lot of fun stuff a lot of
the examples I showed her available here
and then I spent some time doing a very
extensive blog post because I was you
know I was like this is actually scale
for like something non-trivial something
that I would actually write for work so
I I took an autocomplete err like
basically autocomplete errs like combo
box autocomplete errs are actually a
massive pain in the ass to write code
for because it's really complicated
you have to handle tab you have to
handle input blur input focus I mean
it's really crazy the amount of the
venture panel you have to a
synchronously fetched from some server
anyways it's a good non-trivial thing
the autocomplete ER and jquery is like
five hundred lines of code and it's
completely unreadable the Twitter
autocomplete is like thousands of lines
of code completely unreadable nobody can
understand this so I was like it's a
good it's a good example to try can we
build a more sensible system that's
constructive out of reusable components
so here is the auto computer that built
with core async so he can go it's a lot
of things a lot of subtle things work
when I press delete it disappeared right
I press tab right mouse mouse out lots
of subtle things like if you use Google
there's lots of clever things like what
happens if I click drag come back on an
element and it's not the same one if I
click drag and come back on the same one
this is this is all stuff that very
serious autocomplete errs have to do in
order for users to not be completely
pissed off so so this was this was this
was fun so this is actually literate so
I have all the code for the whole thing
and you can read it and you can sort of
see how it works this actually also
works in ie8 so that's the other really
cool thing is like I didn't want it I
didn't want to do that I actually didn't
want to fix it for like there's actually
no problems with the JavaScript there
problems with the CSS I ate was as much
patience as I had but my first blog post
on core async every example on this one
works in ie6 so that's that's the other
thing that's pretty cool is that core
async and we generate very much common
denominator JavaScript we don't do
anything fancy and that I think is
pretty cool
so you can target other browsers old
browsers and right very nice
asynchronous code yeah so that's yeah
Firefox is slow I didn't mean there's
nothing we can do about that I mean I
complain like you know I like Firefox is
slow come on but they're working on it I
mean a lot of a lot of problems with
Firefox are mostly from I can tell
due to garbage collection and they're
working on a generational garbage
collector so hopefully that will fix
closure script on Firefox
well I mean part of the thing that when
I demoed this was that like it's if the
idea is more like that number one if
you're doing that in a mini number of
updates like that's pretty extreme and
it I mean people have already started
building stuff with with Korey sync and
we've done a lot like oh this blog post
was written before we did a bunch of
optimization we've done a ton of
optimization
I actually don't know how we can make it
any faster it's pretty fast fun like for
example here's 100 under a hundred
thousand updates on the DOM and so Cory
sink because we could because we can
basically I didn't talk about this at
all but you can have buffered channels
and buffered channels allow you to
basically split up the work so this is a
buffered channel and you notice the UI
is not locked up it's a hundred thousand
dollar updates that's pretty cool so
there's a lot of flexibility for for
doing interactive stuff other questions
oh that's it so this is what's really
awesome so if you're used to promises or
futures which have a horrible error
handling story in my opinion so I have a
whole blog post and I synchronous error
handling so the go blocks support
try/catch so this is amazing so that
means I can have three independent
asynchronous operation I've written a
little macro and all it does is if
anybody writes an error value on to a
channel when we read it we throw and
this is amazing because you're gonna get
an accurate stack trace right you're
gonna have the original error which has
its stack trace then you're going to
also have where inside your go block it
failed right so it's it's a much nicer
so I'll promise implementations have
used promises in JavaScript because
promises are monadic the end up wrapping
and the stack trace gets obliterated
so you know you know you have to
explicitly handle eros you have to have
to think oh this might fail so I'm gonna
write an error I'm gonna handle I'm
gonna catch the error write it into the
channel so that somebody down upstream
can like catch it and decide what to do
with it which may be you know wrap it
again but but the thing that's still
cool about this is that so normally
normally when you have an error right if
you use like a promises model it's just
you do something you're just gonna get a
mangled stack so this actually allows us
to handle errors across async boundaries
of the event loop right normally the
stack is gone right there's no stack
because you you're it was an
asynchronous top right and you somebody
else was expecting an asynchronous table
so I can throw an error catch it wrap it
in another error throw an error catch it
wrap it and then I could then when I
when I have it I can actually open up
that error and say okay this is a stack
trace at this point in the event loop
this is the stack trace at this point
the event loop this is a stack trace
which is pretty cool
so so there so so a good was so good so
I mean I've sort of alluding to that
with control channels so so you often
like I want to make a channel but I also
want if I get back to channel I want to
give it a control like when I construct
it so if I put anything in the control
the other channel closes it's a common
pattern oh actually a lot of the tricks
that I recommend it's like the go people
they have a lot of tricks and honestly
we mostly just copy the tricks that
we've seen cuz they've been doing this
for a couple years now
other questions
so so so so I mean it like it is
sometimes tricky don't get me wrong like
court like the the the main source of
bugs in Korea Singh it's not like
everything I've shown you is like
awesome because I forked unpin it's like
spent some time putting it together but
so in CSP you have this problem of
deadlock right and that's the problem
where you inadvertently read and then
nobody will ever write or you read and
nobody ever puts write this so no I mean
you you can't really do this but
something that we've been working on
that we just landed a couple weeks ago
that needs more work but it does pretty
much work it which is source maps so
ideally source maps would allow you to
set a breakpoint on the thing and then
when you when you get that spot you'll
be able to at least say what what's what
are my what do my locals look like so
honestly what I've been doing up onto
that point was using just print
debugging and printing out what's going
on so ideally and again I haven't had
time to test this when you set the
breakpoint you get there and you can
look at the stack and like where am i
what's got past in other questions
yep
Oh Oh
um so we're just so rich Akira wrote a
bunch of like a lot of things I've shown
a hand-rolled and so rich recently
landed official version so let all the
stuff that handles closings all this
stuff published subscribe like I didn't
really talk about pub/sub at all and so
he has a lot of stuff around pub/sub a
lot of stuff around pausing resuming
like all these route things that are
really nice when you want to build a
system and you honestly don't want to
have to write yourself they'll be a part
of the standard library so you don't you
know what to do that so that's well
that's really the big day and then a lot
of that stuff I haven't even had a
chance to play around with but I'm
really excited about that cuz that's you
know stuff that people don't - right
yeah definitely still alpha I mean it's
probably gonna be alpha you know for a
little while as people you know try out
the standard library functions I mean a
lot of what I'm showing is just real
primitive right and a lot of my examples
I had to build stuff from scratch so you
know in the next few months people are
gonna stop doing that and use the
standard stuff but people are you
deploying it I know I mean people are
already writing production code it's
pretty I mean the especially on the
closure side it's very solid and there's
been a lot of it's been I've seen a lot
of excitement about closure script
because of Corey Singh you know
front-end devs are like whoa this is
pretty cool I think it's good
you